but i you know people don't understand
this this is a super easy way if you
want to get a reservation to any
restaurant
and every time i have a new assistant i
train them on this
and i would say
on a friday or saturday night i can call
in to the top four restaurants in any
city
and i can get a table in two three or
four
so when i go to a city joel i just tell
my assistant tell me the top 10
restaurants look at eater look at this
look at the local paper
give me the top three or four book me a
table both nights i'm in park city
i want the best restaurant friday and
then the second best one saturday get me
a table six then i figure out who i'm
going to invite
because i'm a foodie and i'm going to
give this to you now joel
because you will appreciate this my
assistant calls
and if you have an assistant that is a
signal right
so say hey i'm calling on behalf of my
boss jason calacanis he's in town for a
conference
with some important uh clients
now you're that's another little tip
okay it's clients
they're important clients and now if you
say it's important clients
that means you're going to try to invest
impress them you can order a next one
and we're very sorry we we know you're
obviously booked
if the in any way there's a cancellation
so you are apologetic
and you're giving them an out and you're
telegraphing to them
that i am going to be baller and then i
tell them look at the wine list pick two
of the expensive bottles of wine
you know 200 bottle wine and say
uh and you know he's a big fan of this
wine
if you had two of them you could put on
the side if something opens up he would
love to have those two bottles just on
the table ready to go
to impress these clients uh and again i
apologize profusely
and it's i know it's ridiculous first
call but you know i'm sure you'll get a
cancellation once in a while because
somebody can't make it or something
somebody flakes and they're like oh
yes and then we have your number when i
tell you this technique works
three or four times sometimes four or
four at the best restaurants
because what i just telegraphed to them
is 400 in alcohol
six people they know we're gonna get a
third bottle
we know we're ordering dessert we're
gonna get some a pair of tea for
something
and that's the other power move if they
got a dessert wine you just pick the
dessert wine which is usually 200 bucks
and now that tells them everything they
need to know yeah everything you need to
know
so smart it works every time
and i that's my gift to everybody in the
this week in startups audience
yeah you have to be able to order 400
wine to make this plan work
but boy does it work no wonder they
don't give me the tables
what what is your technique how do you
get tables when it's hard to get a table
it used to be hard in new york right
just last year it was brutal i heard to
get a table in new york
yeah what's your best techniques so i
would
i would recommend uh i usually go on the
the week weekday nights you know i try
or if i try to sneak in
yeah however if you're trying to make an
impression
uh the first time you go i recommend
buying
one or two uh but usually two nice
bottles of wine
and they'll mark you down actually as a
wine spender and actually so the
signaling that you gave actually tells
them that already
that's so but that's if if you're not
using jason's technique which
which is a really good one then the
other thing i would add is when you do
go to the restaurant
and they don't know you and they didn't
mark those things down or they're not
using seven rooms for that matter
uh you should buy one or two nice
bottles of wine and i guarantee you'll
get a table pretty much 90
of the time you call next time wow what
other techniques are good
what other techniques are good for being
a great customer and getting treated
really well
you have any other hacks yeah i think
just being
obviously calling ahead of time you know
the they're there really is a certain
number of tables and for the
the most popular restaurants you know
the
especially the smaller ones so three
days
or more in advance is great uh
and of course being as friendly as you
can because these folks that are picking
up the
phone or emailing they're getting yelled
at all day long
right they're the don't you know who i
am you guys see that's the thing
with and this is what i trained my my
people on
if you are a hot shot you know what hot
shots do they call and they're humble
that's exactly it that's exactly and i
tell my folks you just
you just if you're super apologetic and
your baller it's like
ugh this person it doesn't need to be
handled with care
and they're going to be delightful and
this is the problem that seven room
solves in a nutshell yeah
is it's so hard for the person picking
up the phone or answering emails to
understand who the customer is because
the most humble people
are actually probably the most
successful people and so
when you call in we can pull up your
profile or when your assistant calls in
so they know without you even having to
tell them
yeah i love the texting too is texting
getting popular because
getting texts to me from a restaurant i
love or whatever and there was this
really interesting product out
here um where it's a little keypad
uh i forgot the name of it you you'll
certainly know it and it's only for
promotions you type in your phone number
while you're leaving
and the front desk has nothing to do
with it you just type it in and then i
did it at this archery place where i was
taking my daughter to this archery place
and then they would just text me every
two or three weeks hey if you come in
two for one today or this weekend
whatever
it was kind of great offers seven it
wasn't seven rooms it was something else
do you know about these like the loyalty
program things yeah absolutely which one
am i describing
there's a few that do those i'm not sure
which one but i'd be curious to find out
yeah what's the best practice in texting
people
because people use it for reservations
now you have to give them your phone
number to get a reservation
what's the best practice should you ask
them would you like promotions or you
just send it to them and
so definitely opting in and then you
know texting
or email you know best practices you
would imagine is
just sending them something they
actually care about and i think that
that's partly also what we're trying to
solve
is without the data you can't possibly
know what they would care about
with the data you can then make those
touch points much more meaningful to
that to the guests to get them to come
back